- We are back in it's
another Rad Mom Hour,
especially for moms who love super loud,
British rock groups from the eighties,
called Spinal Tap.
(everyone laughing)
Ladies, I think you can agree,
two things moms can never get
enough of are appreciation,
thank you,
and relaxation, right?
It feels good. I love it.
(audience applauding)
Well, I have a little
assignment for all of us.
Since being a mom is the only 24/7 job
that gets paid solely in thank you's,
let's each reach out to at
least one other rad mom we know
and shower her with praise.
It'll be nice little bump
in pay, is all I'm saying.
(audience applauding)
Thank you goes a long way.
Now that we have appreciation covered,
let's talk relaxation.
I have the perfect friend to
help us out with vacation ideas
that let you unwind.
Let's welcome back rad travel
mom, Emily Kaufman, everybody.
(audience applauding)
- Hi, Kelly.
- Hello!
It's good to be back with you.
Hi, guys.
- Ugh!
You always look wonderful.
You look like an ocean
breeze just sweeping through.
Every time you come here
I wanna go to an island.
- Ah! That's so nice. Thank you.
- Yeah, it's beautiful.
So what's your number one
travel tip for any mom?
- Well, just do it.
Is really what I wanna say.
- I think Nike took that,
but it's fine.
- Well, yeah.
I gotta be careful
what I say there, right?
- Yeah.
- So, I'm guessing that
you and other moms,
it's probably been a hot minute
since you took the kids
solo, no kids vacation.
- Yeah.
- Am I right?
You know?
- Yeah. Yes.
- So we need some grownup getaways.
So grab your bestie,
grab your sweetie
and just do it.
- So where have you been recently?
Somewhere awesome.
- Somewhere awesome.
I just got back from Oahu.
Have you ever surfed Kelly?
- One time
and I wouldn't call it, I surfed.
- Well,
I sorta kinda surfed too.
- I was on a board.
- I know what you mean.
- [Kelly] I was terrified of sharks.
- I was on Oahu, which is in Waikiki
which is a world famous surf destination.
So I gave it a shot and took a surf lesson
with the Hot Shot Surf School
and I didn't have a lot of success,
but man, I had a lot of fun.
And then the catamaran sunset sail.
- I've never done that.
- Oh, Kelly!
- Yeah.
- [Emily] We need to
get you on a catamaran.
- Well, lets do it.
- I went on a catamaran ride-
- Lets just do it.
- I played that whole look I'm the-
- Titanic?
- King of the world,
Titanic move,
soaring past Diamond Head.
So I found a way to relax
and a way to step out of my comfort zone.
Have a new experience on the
beautiful island of Oahu.
- Yeah. Well, it sounds amazing.
I wanna go.
So maybe we should send
a rad mom in our audience
on that exact trip.
(audience applauding)
- [Emily] I think that sounds good.
- We've got our lights all set up
to land randomly on one
lucky lady in the audience.
So Joe,
hit it.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
- [Emily] Who's it gonna land on?
- Where's it at, where's it at?
(kelly screaming)
(audience cheering)
(women laughing)
- [Kelly] My God, I love this reaction!
- Oh my gosh!
- Wait, so what's your name
and have you ever been to Hawaii?
- I am Angela and I'm
here with my best friend
and we came from Florida to see you and-
- Yeah!
- Yes!
(audience applauding)
And I love Hawaii.
I've only been one time and
it was like 14 years ago.
So I am so excited.
- Oh my gosh. Well, y'all should go.
- She's my partner in crime.
- Yes!
- She's going too.
- You get a trip.
(audience applauding)
All right, well Hawaiian Airlines,
Hawaii's largest and
longest serving airline,
will be flying you and a guest
to the Hilton Hawaiian Village
Waikiki Beach Resort in Oahu.
You'll experience five nights
in a Tapa Collection room,
five different pools, dining
at one of their 20 restaurants
and you'll get to enjoy
the same surf lesson
and catamaran sail, Emily did.
So congratulations.
(audience applauding)
Yes!
Okay, so that's awesome!
Congratulations.
Have you found anywhere else cool.
- Yes, I went to a beautiful
Sandals Resort in Jamaica
and what's so relaxing about it,
is it's luxury included.
They cover your meals,
your alcoholic beverages,
your non-motorized water
sports, your accommodations,
and they have an option for a butler.
Have you ever had a Butler?
- Yes!
- [Emily] It's pretty nice, yeah?
- It's pretty nice.
- Once you go there, you don't go back.
- No, no. It's hard not to.
And at Sandals, you can have
a butler that helps take care
of everything.
- That's amazing. Yeah.
- And then, I also stepped
out of my comfort zone
and challenged myself to do
something I always wanted
to try.
I tried scuba diving.
- [Kelly] Oh! I've never done that.
I wanna do it, but the wetsuit
seems really difficult.
- No, you look good in a wetsuit.
- I know what it takes to get on.
It's like Spanks from hell.
- It takes forever to get on.
- Yeah.
- What was scary for me was,
I thought it was going
to be claustrophobic.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that was very intimidating
for me.
- Yeah.
- But they are PADI
certification at Sandals Resort.
So I was able to take a lesson
and get comfortable-
- Yeah.
- And give myself the opportunity to scuba
and I was so empowered.
- I wanna do that. Yeah.
- After conquering that feeling of fear.
It was pretty cool.
- Oh! That sounds awesome.
(audience applauding)
Well, we need to send
another rad mom there.
So Joe, take it away, again.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly screaming)
(audience applauding)
Oh my God!
(Kelly laughing)
I love the reaction!
So what's your name
and how does beach and
butler service sound to you?
- That sounds amazing.
My name is Tanya Derr
and that's so awesome!
(audience cheering)
- Get your passport ready
because we're sending you and a guest
on a five night luxury included vacation
to Sandals Royal Caribbean
Resort and Private Island,
in Montego Bay, Jamaica.
(audience applauding)
You'll experience luxurious accommodations
in a butler suite,
a couples massage,
(Kelly hooting)
at the award-winning Red Lane Spa,
five star global gourmet dining,
I'm starving,
fresh water pools and so much more.
The pictures! That looks amazing.
(audience applauding)
You're gonna have so much fun.
Oh my gosh. Enjoy!
And thank you, Emily.
- [Emily] Thank you for having me.
- Ugh! Every time you come here
I need to go on a vacation.